este fue el hombre clave en la política
exterior norteamericana de toda la
segunda mitad del siglo XX asesor de
seguridad nacional primero y secretario
de estado después con Richard Nixon
Henry kissinger fue considerado durante
años como la cara pública de la Real
política el pragmatismo por encima de
todo amado por unos y señalado por otros
sus decisiones dieron forma No solo la
política exterior norteamericana sino
también al mundo que conocemos y Singer
por ejemplo fue uno de los grandes
artífices de la apertura de relaciones
entre Estados Unidos y la República
popular china del fin de la guerra de
Vietnam y de la puesta en marcha de las
negociaciones de paz entre Israel y
Egipto un proceso que años después
culminaría con Los acuerdos de Camp
Davis uno de los primeros grandes
acuerdos de paz entre Israel y un país
árabe Pues bien el pasado 27 de mayo de
2023 y Singer cumplió 100 años motivo
por el cual en visualpolitik hemos
querido preparar Este vídeo nos puede
gustar más o menos su figura pero sin
duda y Singer fue uno de los grandes
protagonistas de la política
internacional de todo el siglo XX el
mundo de hoy sería muy diferente quizás
mejor o quizás peor pero en cualquier
caso muy diferente y por eso con este
vídeo queremos responder unas cuantas
preguntas realmente quién fue kissinger
y qué representó para el equilibrio de
poder en la Guerra Fría De qué forma
contribuyó exactamente a dar forma a
nuestro mundo cuáles fueron sus grandes
aciertos y cuál es sus grandes errores
Pues bien en este vídeo queridos amigos
amigas vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas arranquemos
[Aplausos]
pero antes dejadme haceros una pregunta
habéis utilizado ya algún servicio o app
de Inteligencia artificial Seguro seguro
que sí la Inteligencia artificial ha
irrumpido nuestras vidas como un rayo lo
que quizás no veamos a simple vista es
la enorme guerra que se ha desatado
entre empresas y ojo también gobiernos
de todo el mundo por liderar esta
carrera y es que no lo dudéis ni un
segundo Inteligencia artificial puede
ser decisiva por ejemplo en la disputa
que hoy mantiene en China y Estados
Unidos por la hegemonía mundial y no
solo eso Inteligencia artificial también
puede terminar afectando a millones y
millones de puestos de trabajo por tanto
hay unas cuantas preguntas que nos
tendríamos que hacer quién liderará Esta
carrera Qué impacto económico puede
tener esta tecnología destruida
realmente tantos empleos como se dice
pues amigos Alberto nos da todas las
respuestas en el último vídeo de si lo
hubiera sabido el canal de información
financiera mutativos con el que
participamos os dejamos el enlace en la
descripción y ahora sí sigamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
año 1969 Estados Unidos tiene su
inventario más de 26.000 armas nucleares
miles de bases militares repartidas por
toda Europa y numerosas flotas
repartidas por los mares de todo el
mundo todo absolutamente todo está
preparado para luchar contra el Imperio
rojo la Guerra Fría amigos atraviesa sus
años más difíciles y en ese momento el
mundo era un lugar peligroso y no solo
estoy hablando del posible Armagedón
nuclear también del choque entre India y
Pakistán del creciente caos en América
Latina la descolonización de África o el
conflicto árabe israelí entre muchos
otros además la caída en la unión
soviética de nikitakussef en 1964 y su
recambio por Leon brenneth supuso El
regreso a una línea más dura y la pausa
de cualquier distensión prácticamente
podemos decir que el mundo se había
convertido en un enorme barril de
pólvora y cualquier Mecha lo podía hacer
estallar en mil pedazos había que
evitarlo tocaba echar el freno y reducir
la tensión Pero la pregunta es cómo
amigos en de 1968 el republicano Richard
Nixon ganó las elecciones presidenciales
le tocaba entonces escoger al nuevo guía
de la política internacional y sabéis
que justo ahí fue Cuando comenzó la era
kissinger pero no vayamos tan rápido
[Música]
a quien todos conocemos como Jerry
kissinger en realidad nació bajo el
nombre de heinz Alfred kissinger un 27
de mayo de 1923 en baviera Alemania solo
10 años antes de que el nazismo llegara
al poder su familia era judía alemana
Así que la llegada de 1933 de adolf
Hitler al poder cambió sus vidas para
siempre las medidas de segregación nazis
fueron poco a poco expulsándoles de la
vida civil hasta que finalmente en 1938
cuando kissinger tenía 15 años su
familia consiguió huir de Alemania
primero a Reino Unido y luego a Estados
Unidos
[Música]
concretamente a Nueva York donde
terminaría matriculándose en el city
college para estudiar la carrera de
contabilidad pero sea como sea en 1943
kissinger adquirió la nacionalidad
norteamericana y ese mismo año fue
reclutado y enviado al frente europeo
donde gracias a saber hablar alemán
tener acento local terminó como
comandante de un destacamento del cuerpo
de contrainteligencia lo que si lo
pensáis un momento supuso todo un
sorprendente giro en los acontecimientos
y Singer que había llegado con su
familia huyendo de Alemania como un
judío perseguido había regresado a su
país natal convertido ya en ciudadano de
los Estados Unidos de América con la
misión de pelear una guerra abierta
contra el régimen nazi vaya vueltas que
da la vida con todo lo más trascendente
estaba aún por llegar fijaos
cuando kissinger volvió a Estados Unidos
algo en él había cambiado ya no quería
estudiar contabilidad toda su vida había
estado profundamente condicionada por
decisiones políticas y ahora su pasión
por esta actividad se había encendido de
forma Irreversible y como decimos por
aquí dicho y hecho en 1950 se graduó con
honores como licenciado en ciencias
políticas por la universidad de Harvard
y pocos años después obtendría su
doctorado en esta misma universidad
y así poco a poco se fue incorporando
los círculos que daban forma a la
política internacional de este país y
single hizo trabajos para el consejo de
relaciones exteriores el departamento de
estado y la corporación Ram sin embargo
el rol que le acercaría de forma clave
al poder fue la oferta que recibió para
trabajar como asesor de política
exterior en las campañas presidenciales
de Nelson rockefeller entonces
gobernador de Nueva York y oponente en
las primarias republicanas de un tal
Richard Nixon y singers estaba situando
a las puertas del poder pero amigos
amigas aún no estaba dentro atentos
[Música]
un mundo en llamas
el día 5 de noviembre de 1968 Richard
milhouse Nixon ganó las elecciones
presidenciales se convertiría en El
trigésimo séptimo presidente de los
Estados Unidos en un mundo que era de
todo menos un lugar apacible y tranquilo
y no no estoy exagerando si hoy la
Guerra de Ucrania aparece No sé un
conflicto capaz de sacudir Los cimientos
del orden internacional imaginémonos por
un momento Cuál era la situación a
finales de los años 60 en ese momento
Estados Unidos ya había perdido cerca de
17.000 soldados en Vietnam la unión
soviética Había decidido invadir
Checoslovaquia y Oriente medio era un
polvorín tras la guerra de los seis días
y el triunfo del nacionalismo en Egipto
Y por supuesto entre medias había miles
y miles de cabezas nucleares preparadas
para hacer estallar el mundo y por si
fuera poco el asesinato del presidente
Kennedy el movimiento contra la guerra
de Vietnam y la lucha definitiva contra
la segregación racial estaban generando
fortísimas tensiones dentro de la
sociedad Norte y este amigo será el
contexto al que se enfrentaba el nuevo
presidente republicano Richard Nixon
[Música]
tras su Victoria electoral Nixon invitó
aquí singular sus oficinas de Nueva York
para conocerlo más de cerca la reunión
de vivir muy bien porque apenas unas
pocas semanas después Nixon le ofreció a
kissinger rimas ni menos que el cargo de
asesor de seguridad nacional el segundo
puesto de mayor Rango en el gabinete que
no requería Confirmación del senado el
primero era el del propio jefe de
gabinete
[Música]
Claro que la expectación que aquí single
parecía haber generado Nixon no era
recíproca para que os hagáis una idea
Esto fue lo que le dijo a nuestro
protagonista su antiguo jefe el
gobernador rockefeller me reprendió por
posponer mi decisión y me instó a
aceptar de inmediato la oferta de Nixon
cuando el presidente te invita a un
servicio importante observó la demora no
es una respuesta adecuada ten en cuenta
agregó rockefeller que Nixon está
corriendo un riesgo mucho mayor contigo
de lo que tú estás corriendo con él esa
misma tarde llamé por teléfono a Nixon
Henry sin nger en su libro liderazgo
seis estudios sobre estrategia mundial
nuestro protagonista de hoy ya tenía su
plaza en lo más alto del Poder y aquí
aquí es cuando empieza de verdad toda
esta historia atentos
[Música]
tres goles por toda la escuadra
en agosto de 1968 en plena campaña
electoral norteamericana el mandamás de
la unión soviética ordenó una
intervención militar sobre
Checoslovaquia lo hizo después de que
este país miembro del Pacto de Varsovia
y liderado por el presidente Alexander
anunciará un paquete de reformas para la
liberalización económica y política algo
que la unión soviética no Estaba
dispuesta a consentir y es que veréis
por aquel tiempo la superpotencia
comunista estaba atravesando lo que en
Washington denominaban como el
estancamiento bretneviano la economía
soviética había comenzado a mostrar sus
primeras grandes grietas y ya no era
capaz de seguirle el paso a los Estados
Unidos Pues bien pese a la invasión de
Checoslovaquia y Singer Consideró que
era el momento perfecto para promover un
acercamiento su tesis es que Estados
Unidos no tenía que buscar hacer leña
del árbol caído con los problemas
soviéticos sino aprovechar el momento
para lograr pequeños cambios esto es por
ejemplo lo que explica la visita del
antiguo líder de la Rumanía comunista
Nicolás Washington en 1969 y las
posteriores visitadas de Nixon a
yugoslavia Polonia y naturalmente
también
Moscú múltiples ocasiones y lo cierto es
que esta estrategia en cierta forma
funcionó las relaciones mejoraron y en
1971 Incluso se logró la firma del
tratado Salt para limitar el Arsenal
nuclear de ambas potencias
Claro que la Guerra Fría no era el único
quebradero de cabeza en Washington
[Música]
En aquel momento la guerra de Vietnam se
estaba convirtiendo ya en toda una
pesadilla una guerra e interminable cada
vez más costosa y sobre todo cada vez
más impopular estaba Claro que Estados
Unidos tenía que buscar una salida pero
la pregunta es cuál pensad que para
cuando Nixon juró como presidente
Estados Unidos tenía más de 500.000
soldados desplegados en Vietnam era una
situación completamente insostenible por
eso el nuevo presidente le encomendó
nada más empezar su mandato su gabinete
lograr el fin de la guerra y el retiro
de las tropas durante el primer mandato
ya sabéis la guerra no podía afectar de
ninguna forma a su reelección Pues bien
para 1973 el conflicto ya estaba a punto
de llegar a su fin algo por lo que El
Revolucionario vietnamita le duchó y
Henry sin que recibieron el Nobel de la
paz Aunque el asiático no lo aceptó por
considerar que el conflicto estaba un en
curso
no fue hasta 1975 con la caída de saigón
cuando 20 años después y de una vez por
todas este desastre militar y político
para Estados Unidos llegó a su fin
[Música]
amigos las gestiones para lograr el
deshielo político con la unión soviética
y su papel para lograr el fin de la
guerra de Vietnam le valieron a
kissinger un ascenso y menudo ascenso
sin abandonar su puesto como asesor de
seguridad nacional Nixon también le dio
la secretaría de estado de esta forma
Henry Singer se convirtió en uno de los
personajes más importantes de toda la
historia de la política internacional
norteamericana pocas personas han
acumulado tanto peso dentro de un
gabinete algo que la nueva Rockstar de
la política internacional de América
utilizó para desplegar lo que se conoce
como la satel diplomas y la diplomacia
triangular esto es Buscar la
aproximación de dos países hostiles
mediante la intervención de un tercer
actor que sea amigable para las dos
partes que fue por cierto precisamente
la estrategia que kissinger empleo en
Oriente medio
[Aplausos]
Y es que veréis en 1973 ya os hemos
dicho que este era un mundo más que
Movidito se produjo también la guerra
del yom kippur donde Egipto y Siria se
lanzaron en trompa contra Israel Pues
bien kissinger utilizó esta especie de
apuesta triangular para convertirse en
el intermediario entre la jefa de
gobierno israelí y Golden Meyer y el
presidente egipcio el sadat y no solo
eso el nuevo líder de la política
internacional de Estados Unidos también
invitó a la unión soviética a la ronda
de negociaciones y Singer de hecho llegó
incluso a plantear la posibilidad de
crear una fuerza de la ONU integrada por
ambas superpotencias para pacificar las
cercanías al Canal de suez la idea no
prosperó pero tropas de Estados Unidos y
la unión soviética codo con codo no me
digáis que el tipo no era atrevido El
caso es que el conflicto del yom kippur
terminó en 19 días y el acercamiento de
Israel y Egipto que promovió que Singer
no sólo de vino en un ces al fuego sino
que culminó con la visita de sabat a
Israel a finales de 1977 y los acuerdos
de Candy del 78 Ya bajo la
administración de cárter pero
recapitulemos en apenas cuatro años y
singunger había logrado la salida de
Vietnam un histórico acercamiento a la
unión soviética un importantísimo
acuerdo nuclear Y para colmo también el
cese del fuego en el polvorín de oriente
medio no sé no parece mal resultado para
tan poco tiempo sin embargo esperad un
momento porque su gran obra la obra que
probablemente ha cambiado el mundo más
que cualquier otra estaba aún por llegar
y sí naturalmente estamos hablando de
China atentos
[Música]
China la Obra maestra
sabéis se suele pensar que la idea de
estrechar relaciones con china fue de
kissinger pero en realidad esta era una
apuesta que ya Richard Nixon había
defendido años antes de llegar a la casa
blanca fijaos desde una perspectiva a
largo plazo no podemos permitirnos dejar
a China para siempre fuera de la familia
de Naciones allí para alimentar a sus
fanáticos abrigar sus odios y amenazar a
sus vecinos no hay lugar en este pequeño
planeta para que mil millones de sus
habitantes potencialmente más capaces
vivan en un airado aislamiento Y si
after Vietnam paper publicado por
Richard Nixon en foreina First octubre
de 1967 con todo kissinger y Nixon
coincidían en el diagnóstico sin embargo
acercarse a Pekín no resultaba nada pero
que nada fácil qué pasaría con los
compromisos asumidos con Taiwán Cómo
acercarse a un país tan cerrado y hostil
realmente era factible estrechar lazos
con la china de Mao Pues digamos que
aquí en las de kissinger fue también la
diplomacia triangular Y es que veréis
cuando visitó Estados Unidos en el 69
Nixon en personal le pidió que le
hiciera saber al gobierno de Mao que
quería establecer conversaciones entre
los dos gobiernos recordemos que en ese
Washington pues seguía reconociendo a la
República china esto es a Taiwán y no a
la República popular china como la china
legítima Pues bien El caso es que el
ofrecimiento de Washington cayó en saco
roto por eso al año siguiente le pidió
al embajador norteamericano en Polonia
que le trasladara el mensaje al primer
diplomático chino con el que coincidiera
lógicamente el correo electrónico en esa
época no era una opción cómo han
cambiado las cosas
[Música]
la oportunidad llegaría Poco después en
un evento social yugoslavo y gracias a
ello en diciembre de 1970 se produjo el
primer contacto oficial entre Nixon y el
premiere lo que haya en el camino para
que en 1971 y sin realizara visitas
secretas a la china comunista para
acordar los términos de la nueva
relación que estaba a punto de nacer el
viaje secreto se organizó programando
una visita mía a Vietnam Tailandia India
y Pakistán una vez en islamaba se
anunció una indisposición que explicaría
mi subsiguiente ausencia de dos días
como una visita una estación de montaña
para recuperarme todo el proceso desde
la conversación de Nixon con yeyak en el
25 de octubre de 1970 hasta mi llegada a
Pekín el 9 de julio de 1971 duró ocho
meses Henry kissinger en su libro
liderazgo seis estudios sobre estrategia
mundial Poco después el anuncio de la
visita del propio Richard Nixon a China
abriría definitivamente una nueva era
el 25 de octubre de 1971 el consejo de
seguridad de la ONU reconoció
definitivamente a la República Popular
de China como la auténtica China
Eso sí pese Nunca logró que Estados
Unidos minimizará sus compromisos con
Taiwán
other people in the Garden
queridos amigos amigas en el caso de
China la posición de kissinger era que
las naciones con capacidad de fuego no
podían vivir al margen del sistema
internacional de la diplomacia y del
orden global porque aislarlas terminaría
provocando conductas destructivas en ese
juego sacrificar el reconocimiento a
Taiwán era algo digamos asumible es la
cruda definición de lo que conocemos
como real política una estrategia
política que al igual que el propio
kissinger aglutina tantos admiradores
como detra
luces y Sombras
[Música]
Los acuerdos con la unión soviética la
reconciliación con china el fin de la
guerra de Vietnam las negociaciones de
paz en Oriente medio está amigos es
quizás la mejor cara de la apuesta
política de kissinger otras caras En
cambio no generan tantas admiración por
ejemplo kissinger no dudó en apoyar
diferentes tipos de guerra sucia y
dictadores con tal de frenar la
expansión del comunismo en América
Latina qué Ricky Singer cumple 100 años
el controvertido Nobel de la paz que
apoyó la guerra sucia que dejó miles de
muertos en América Latina esta que Vais
a ver por ejemplo es una frase muy
conocida que kissinger dirigió al
almirante argentino César Augusto Gucci
canciller del golpe militar liderado por
Jorge Rafael Videla que se había
perpetrado hacia apenas tres meses si
hay cosas que deben ser hechas deberían
hacerla rápido pero deben volver
rápidamente a los procedimientos
normales Henry kissinger parece claro de
lo que está hablando no os parece
represión y persecución la real política
en su máxima expresión también fue muy
controvertida su política de ampliarnos
un bombardeos masivos sobre Camboya y
laos para debilitar al vizcon antes de
sentarse a negociar pero pese a todo una
encuesta realizada en 15 entre
académicos norteamericanos lo catalogó
como el secretario de estado más
eficiente de los últimos 50 años fijaos
siguiendo un poco esta misma Estela por
cierto kissinger defiende hoy por hoy el
diálogo con la Rusia de Putin pero sea
como sea si algo está claro es que pesa
sus luces y sus sombras y ya seamos más
o menos partidarios de esta forma cruda
de hacer política internacional en la
que todo vale incluso abrazarte a los
peores regímenes del mundo y Singer
contribuyó a dar forma al mundo que hoy
conocemos dicho esto La pregunta es para
ti qué opinión te merece el legado de
Henry kissinger Qué te parece su Apuesta
por la real política consideras que su
papel fue bueno o malo déjanos como
siempre tus impresiones en los
comentarios y hablamos debate y ahora si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
No olvides darle a like y suscribirte a
visualpolitik si es que aún no lo has
hecho Ah e importante no olvides echarle
también un vistazo al vídeo de si lo
hubiera sabido una vez más Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]